good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast and happy Friday
Friday gotta get down on Friday
we have a gorgeous very special Friday
episode for you guys today I am back in
studio in our Florida headquarters toast
HQ transatlantic Edition and I'm sitting
down I figured you know while I have
Jackie's Studio at my disposal why don't
we give Jax a day off let her ease into
the weekend alarm free living and I
could sit down with honestly annoyingly
one of the most requested co-hosts in
the toast Universe I just realized
you're not wearing shoes is that a
problem that's just crazy like
celebrities don't have to wear shoes you
know I just like hopped off the golf
course came here just like living that
life
um did you bring shoes to Jackie's house
no you drove without shoes no I wore my
new blue Birkenstocks that I purchased
at Target they're not Birkenstock brand
they're they're nice they're just not
Birkenstock brand no no they're not and
I wouldn't wear a Birkenstock brand
because Birkenstock brand ripped off now
is an Israeli company that's very true
but and these Birkenstock
non-birkenstock blue shoes are
waterproof
and Incredibly uncomfortable so I just
no it's insane it's insane I want to
just address the people watching on
YouTube because we are doing video today
um I guess like feet are good for
engagement so that's fine and that
happens to be the foot this is a good
foot yeah you have a wonky toe on the
other foot don't do it don't do it just
put no no it's the second one down down
but down dog other foot uh just stop
when did people start calling feet dogs
I don't know that's a good question
right it's strange isn't it isn't it
like put away your dogs like put them
dogs away like why
wow your feet are looking quite dogish
today they're looking literally
unbelievable I don't even know like like
what are you even talking about I never
really look at your feet they're kind of
um
like crazy what's wrong with them
they're not like a gorgeous foot it's a
pretty nice foot you could do much worse
the shape of your big toe is insane no
no it's a perfect foot for me it's a
great foot
what's wrong with my foot your big toe
just looks like member and Spy Kids
those like um thumbs of course that's
what your big toe looks like oh my big
toe looks like a thumb toe which it is
wow wow
let me guess you don't like my pinky toe
because it's small
now your pinky toe is fine yeah let's
see your feet I got a pedicure I'm
looking good hmm
it's a nice foot now it always is so
let's just issue an apology to everybody
watching on YouTube you are gonna have
to stare at Ben's bare feet if I hadn't
noticed before we started recording that
you're wearing shoes I would have sent
you downstairs put your shoes on
interesting and then you could have
talked about your new shoes that we got
a Target yesterday fine you want me to
go get my shoes no you're fine
um we went to Target yesterday we had
kind of like an amazing day out we went
to Outback Steakhouse we did we went to
Target we did I filmed a tick tock at
Outback Steakhouse and I will be posting
it today so our review is pending but
let's give the The Toasters like a brief
sneak peek what did you think of Target
no of Outback Steakhouse we'd both never
been it was our first time of course
I've seen the commercials I know about
the bloom and onion by the way you've
been saying that I've been to Outback
that's how I knew to order the Bloomin
Onion with who your girlfriend no with
my parents same and just like I don't
know no I by the way I've never been to
Outback and even I know you get the
bloom and onion because I've seen the
commercials yeah see Outback is Outback
is a solid establishment you're looking
for a safe meal in a town where you just
you don't know what's safe and what
isn't you don't know if you're gonna
walk in here get food poisoning from the
tuna you don't know you don't know you
can trust that Outback's got your back
do you think that's a slogan no it's
Outback oh true true it was getting
Aussie Aussie Aussie
and that really begs the question like
we just kind of accept
that The Branding of Outback is
Australian now I've never been to
Australia and I don't think I've ever
eaten Australian food but is Steakhouse
Australian Cuisine like what makes
Outback Australian
I'm not sure I think that uh the whole
down under thing is like kind of like
you know it's like the wild west isn't
it it's like it's like the western part
of Australia when they say down under I
like Safari no not like Safari like more
like cowboys and Indians I believe
honestly like the so when you think of
like steakhouses like steakhouses or
like let's let's Rope Rope them cows
excuse me no I don't know I think it's
just like a marketing thing that we've
all sort of just
gone with but yesterday I was thinking
critically at Outback Steakhouse what
about Outback whether it be the
restaurant interior design the cuisine
the menu what about it is Australian you
are trying to cancel Outback no I'm not
I just feel like nobody's been asking
you questions another fine establishment
canceled that's untrue once you see my
review you're gonna see I actually
really enjoyed myself there I'm just
critically thinking about appac when I
feel like nobody has I've been seeing
those commercials with that guy out back
down under I've been seeing it good I
I've been seeing it since I was a child
and I just sort of accepted it but now
I'm a critically thinking adult and I'm
just asking questions and I don't think
it's ever bad to ask questions I assume
that one of the owners the original
owners well it's from Down Under and
maybe maybe just maybe the original
Outback was in Australia or maybe it's
like Lacroix which everybody thought was
Lacroix from France scanned in Wisconsin
that's but it's a Lacroix effect it is
right it's Lacroix beer manufacturing
but so then to that point nobody ever
looked at Outback and said oh I want
that Australian feeling you know they're
going there for like a cheap steak okay
but now let's think even more critically
we actually have had Australian Cuisine
once when we went to rubies delicious
what were we eating there pasta no by
the way nothing there was Australian
okay wait what is Australian Cuisine
precisely my initial question
should we Google no you sure yeah you
don't want to know no but as long as you
should know I prefer to talk about
things I don't know not like actually
find them out you know really yeah
I like to know no
um so we went to Outback Steakhouse
yesterday
and it was great
it was fine yeah Ben didn't have as good
of an experience as I did no no The
Vibes Immaculate you walk in big
beautiful booths Hostess lovely waitress
lovely they're so ask for a lemon give
us six yeah big sodas giving that was
that by the way and that was the exact
type of energy I was looking for when we
were scouring you know the neighborhood
for somewhere to eat I wanted like a big
comfy Booth with a big soda and that's
just like a chain restaurant Vibe so
when we passed Outback it was kind of
meant to be it was it was you were
skeptical at first but I was you are
looking for an Outback you knew what I
needed you didn't share with me that you
had already been to an Outback with your
girlfriend I did share it what else do
you and your girlfriend do I got married
at Outback
I got married in Italy did I say you
stole my wedding country
it's a cultural reference I understand
where's it from no I understood that it
was a cultural reference I didn't think
that you were speaking to me guess where
it's from
movie right no damn
I didn't even get the category right
Keeping Up with the Kardashians oh well
the Kardashians on Hulu but same thing
um okay so we have a bunch of stories
today we actually have a lot of loose
ends we need to tie up a Megan Fox
update with her GoFundMe Saga we have a
Francia Rhys Selena Gomez update and I
have briefed Ben while he was in the
shower this morning on everything up
until this point so he knows a bunch of
the background and he had taken a
particular interest actually he poked
his head out of the shower this morning
he's was asking me questions about
what's going on with Ariana Grande
you want to know why I asked you because
you figured we were talking about it no
yes you wake up in the morning I know
you know sometimes a song is just stuck
in your head and for whatever reason the
song that was stuck in my head was
game and put him down SpongeBob turned
into a clown and nobody ever wants to
dance with a fool who went in ripped his
pants and while I know that Ariana
Grande is not actually dating the
character from SpongeBob voice actor for
whatever reason the two went into my
head she is dating
um uh pretty not famous low-level actor
whose recent claim to fame was that he
was in SpongeBob the musical playing
SpongeBob live on stage oh wait I
thought that I thought that the wife oh
oh oh wait what I thought that the wife
of the person who was the SpongeBob
voice actor came out and said no they're
not dating it was her that was another
part of the story but whenever when it
came out that Ariana was dating Ethan
Slater everyone was like who the [__] is
wait so he is the voice of SpongeBob no
he played SpongeBob on and not maybe not
Broadway maybe Broadway there was a
Spongebob live action Musical on stage
and he was the the SpongeBob character
got it so he's SpongeBob no but he's not
a SpongeBob but literally everybody came
out and said no not SpongeBob he's
SpongeBob he's not SpongeBob and the
reason that that the actual voice actor
of the iconic SpongeBob actor came out
and was like this is not my husband it's
the guy from The Broadway version of it
because everybody thought her husband
was sleeping with Ariana Grande
comment and was like guys this isn't me
um we're actually about to celebrate
like our 40th anniversary they're like
much older I understand so there was
confusion but you had the you made the
connection correctly I did he's widely
known for his you know amazing role as
SpongeBob in the SpongeBob play on stage
which how many people have seen 17. I
just like I didn't even know that
SpongeBob was on board how do you put
SpongeBob on Broadway well you should
watch some of the clips that are coming
out of Ethan's performance it's giving
major cringe really yeah he's not good
I'll say he's fine you know he's like a
trained professional you know on stage
on stage performer but you know
SpongeBob on stage is just a weird play
it's a terrible concept like I don't
even know why you would do it it's
almost as bad as Aladdin did you see
Aladdin no you went without me horrible
horrible if you love Aladdin don't see
it
so we're in the magic if you love Lion
King
see that yeah see that so Ben has been
briefed we have a bunch of updates and
we're gonna get your thoughts you know
on infidelity on GoFundMe uh
of course
literally I just want like the record to
show I came here with beautifully
manicured feet and I was just thrown to
the wolves and now all of a sudden I am
being mocked for my my stutter do you
like want some sort of an apology I'm
sorry that I I have a problem you do but
you're not gonna get it ready
Freddy here are the fast five stories
that you need to
no
gotcha
you've been got
all right you guys today's episode is
brought to you by liquid Ivy the number
one powered hydration brand in America
is now available in sugar-free gears in
the making the hydration multiplier
sugar-free uses a proprietary zero sugar
hydration solution with no artificial
sweeteners with three times the
electrolytes of the leading sports drink
plus eight vitamins and nutrients for
everyday Wellness liquid IV hydrates two
times faster than water alone so keep
your daily routine exciting with three
new flavors white peach green grape and
lemon lime I love liquid IV I think
their flavors are amazing I drink them
all the time because I never drink water
I always have one in my purse because
when I travel or if I'm getting hungover
if I'm prone to migraines when I travel
um it's just always like a really good
thing to have on your person have in
your house it's great for hangovers but
if you two struggle with just like
staying on top of your hydration
liquidity is a great brand for you and
now their zero sugar is amazing for
hangovers the flavors are so good white
peach
so one stick of liquid IV goes into 16
ounces of water and it hydrates you two
times faster and more efficient than
water alone the results of an extensive
research and development process
perfected the flavor and efficacy they
combined science-backed zero sugar
technology with the Brand's commitment
to delicious real flavor so it's non-GMO
it's free from gluten dairy and soy it
contains eight vitamins and nutrients
for everyday wellness and it has three
times the electrolytes of the leading
sport strings so they're real people
real flavor real hydrating now
sugar-free grab your liquid IV hydration
multiplier sugar-free and bulk
nationwide at Costco or get 20 off when
you go to liquid iv.com use code toast
at checkout that's 20 off anything when
you order using promo code toast at
liquid iv.com today's episode is also
brought to you by Squarespace so
Squarespace is the end-all be-all when
it comes to websites it is the
all-in-one website platform for
entrepreneurs to stand out and succeed
online so whether you're just starting
out or managing a growing brand
Squarespace makes it easy to create a
beautiful website engage with your
audience and sell anything from products
to content to time all in one place all
on your terms so if you've been wanted
to start a website for your business if
you want to start an e-commerce business
if you have a side hustle you need a
website and we know it's pretty much
like impossible to create your own
website these days I feel like you need
a special college degree for it not all
of us are Engineers Squarespace is out
here doing all the work for you it is so
easy they have these stunning templates
and once you get your website up and
running it will look like you paid a
company like a ton of money to do it but
all you did was use Squarespace and they
have fabulous features so whatever type
of website you're trying to build if
you're trying to sell merch you can
easily sell custom merch you can create
passive income that engages your
audience and scales your brand if you
want to create an online store you can
sell your products on a Squarespace
online store
um their website templates are super
flexible they're really professional
looking and with designs for every
category and use case you can customize
your look update your content and add
features that fit your unique needs
Drive sales and engage your audience
with Squarespace email campaigns you can
easily collect subscribers on your site
and build connections with repeat
business through regular email updates
so we of course have a code for our
girlies head to squarespace.com toast to
save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or a domain using Code toast
that's squarespace.com toast to save 10
on your first purchase of a website or a
domain using Code toast alright Pepsi
website polka dot say how to waifu's
name was lotsi are you ready for the
Fast Five
yes did you not feel like answering me
today no I mean yes I'm ready I've been
ready okay I'm not I'm ready I'm not I'm
not just give me a second I'm like doing
it all today you know all right stories
if we want before we dive in we can talk
about bed bugs or no bed bugs let's just
clear the record before you're about to
say we don't have bed bugs no we don't
have bed bugs so why the [__] do you
want to talk I'm just saying you didn't
want to jump into the Fast Five yet and
something's been on my mind so in case
you want to go on a random tangent we
can you are more than welcome to say
what's on your mind but um I never said
I didn't want to dive in but please no
you were saying that you know there's a
lot going on okay go
the expression oh yes
sleep tight don't let the bedbugs bite
that we say to our young children bless
you we say to our young children isn't
that really on the parent for not
cleaning the kids sheets why would there
be bed bugs in the kids bed it's a good
question
so what are you going to say to our
future children you have to save a
problem good night sleep tight I love
you sleep well why would the bedbugs
bite I did your sheets why would you
have bed bugs oh so in this hypothetical
scenario you're changing and cleaning
the sheets no you but like your mama
cleaned the sheets but even if I clean
the sheet to get bed bugs it's just like
it's so it's disgusting it's disgusting
and why would you think that your
children would have bed bugs why would
you put that in their heads no it's a
good question I think you know this is
something that
a lot of people experience when they
become parents is you find the dark
origins of like classic limericks songs
uh ashes ashes We All Fall Down
that's like a if you look into the
history of that it's very dark it's
something about a cemetery I don't know
what about Rock-a-bye Baby on the
treetop when the wind blows the crater
will rock when the bell breaks the
crater will fall and down will come baby
oh my God
story of a baby dying right like it's a
baby in a tree yep falling to its death
he is I'm just saying I thought I needed
to bring this up I'm so glad you did you
should talk it up with Jackie you know
she's mum see what types of riddles
she's bringing into her home if only
somebody could write a children's book
for the Modern Age the camber in the
counselor.com
that's five seamless I love that now for
those who may be new here you know we're
constantly growing I forgot to mention
Ben is my husband just in case anybody
didn't know that he's a big celebrity
he's the founder of Spar uh Spritz
Society our sparkling canned wine
cocktail that we started together
um we actually just launched merch
yesterday if you want to check out
Sports society.com he also hosts his own
podcast called Good Guys hosted with
Josh Peck who's kind of an A-list
celebrity these days since he's been in
Oppenheimer do you feel threatened at
all like you know when you guys first
started the podcast of course Josh was
much more famous than you he's an iconic
actor Drake and Josh he was a former
member of the Vlog Squad big influencer
but you know the difference between you
guys wasn't that big you were in the
same space but Josh is in Oppenheimer
how do you feel
you know threatened no not threatened
but I as we've been talking about sag
everybody's on strike you know I feel
left out of the club you did as a fellow
celebrity yeah I really should be on
insect yeah I should be insane you can
stand in solidarity with the strike
though and my Fran dreschner I just I
just want to be yeah dresser you said
okay for one second you said literally
you wanted me to say dressner no I
didn't want anything I was just
listening
by the way we we're going to Union
against you I'm gonna who's we I don't
know me Theo Josh oh you're starting
you're going on strike against me yeah
okay I'll pull all your ads don't forget
I'm your boss [__] interesting I run
TNN I run this town interesting you see
you see it's his name Bob Odenkirk or is
that the actor
Bob Iger yeah
in this situation and I'm for him you're
a friend yeah but we want Fair wages are
you not getting wage Fair wages no well
how so because streaming we don't stream
we do where here this is live this is
stream this is essentially a webcam I
don't know where you're putting this the
internet is a free market
hmm
you bring up an interesting point it's
closed case close we got a deal very
good okay let's dive into the stories so
I was telling you and we were talking
about the toast earlier that Megan Fox
earlier this week posted to GoFundMe for
she said her Nail Tech whose father had
been diagnosed with cancer they were
raising about thirty thousand dollars
fans were quick to notice
um you know Megan Fox could easily clear
that 30k in a matter of moments and you
know on gofundme.com you can actually
look through all the donations thus far
you could sort by highest to lowest and
the highest donation was 300 so there's
no proof that that was Megan Fox and if
it was 300 it's like come on girl so
people were like girl read the room in
this economy you're a celebrity pay it
she got a bunch of um backlash and now
she has responded to the backlash after
asking fans to help with her friends
GoFundMe I will read you her statement
that she posted it's very aggressive she
posted it on her Instagram story just
you know a little text you know nothing
crazy hey weirdos
do any of you have the emotional
intelligence to consider that maybe Brit
the nail tech doesn't want her celebrity
clients donating large sums of money to
her because it creates a dynamic in her
working relationships That Make Her
uncomfortable so instead she asked me to
post the GoFundMe so that many people
could donate small amounts of money to
help them Reach their goal I just
obliged her request anything she needs
from me personally she will ask and I
Will Do privately one thing you're not
going to accuse me of is being miserly
or lacking generosity so try again on
another day probably tomorrow with some
different [__] you bunch of psychos
so she came out swinging but pretty much
what she said me and Jackie were like
you know what you never know she
probably donated in private like let's
not jump but she pretty much admitted
that she didn't donate because her
friend didn't ask
I have like a weird thing with Megan Fox
what where I think I feel bad for her
how so there's just like something like
I'm sure that's there she's in a loving
relationship machine and Kelly all that
stuff it's just like something where I
just always feel like Megan Fox is maybe
it's just because I recently saw a video
of like his security like pushing her up
against a barrel that was sad and then
all of a sudden they just like both walk
off where she's trying not to make it a
scene but clearly she's in pain and
probably wants to cry but she's just
like oh the cameras are on me I'm just
gonna like I just feel like their life
is like so unbelievably chaotic in
public and
she no matter what she does she's always
talked about and I actually don't think
that it's a big deal like I think it's a
nice thing to post a link for for
someone who needs a GoFundMe and it is
very easy for people to give little
checks if they care about it and I'd
like to give the benefit of the doubt
that if how much money was raised
I mean at this point I'm not entirely
sure the goal was thirty thousand
dollars here GoFundMe the goal was 60
excuse me and as of right now even with
all the Press they've raised eight
thousand okay so I would assume
or I would think that if Megan Fox has
the means she finishes it right like she
does the extra 52 to get this woman to
60. maybe not but I'd also like to point
out that just because you're a celebrity
and just because your net worth says
that you have X she could be completely
broke so what we talked about the other
day um with Jackie and I is you know we
Dove deep into her finances we're like
it's entirely possible that she's
actually not liquid she's always famous
um she's always being spoken about but
she's never being spoken about her work
but she was in three Transformers movies
and those are like major no I get it but
like you just you just never know like
is she
I don't know you're continuing to give
her the benefit of the doubt which is
nice because I'm currently thinking in
in her statement she basically admitted
that her friend didn't ask her for money
so she didn't give her any money how
close are they it's his friend it's her
Nail Tech I get it are they friends I
don't know if you're friendly enough to
I don't know I just think like no if I
was Megan Fox and this woman asked me to
post her GoFundMe I would probably just
give her the money instead of posting it
because I I would know the backlash
but maybe she didn't know the backlash
it's happening it's happened with
celebrities before I just I think truly
what happened is these people are not
friends this is Megan Fox's Nail Tech
her Nail Tech came to her with
a question I'm sick I need money from
her father oh my father is sick and
Megan Fox was like oh man like I can't
believe you came to to me with this what
am I supposed to do all right I'll post
it for you but they're not friends which
is why she didn't give her the money and
she did this as a favor and now it's all
coming back she's not giving her the
money to pay rent it's like her father
is sick with cancer honestly I don't
like this response from Megan uh Fox
it's like weirdly aggressive and she
very much says Rick didn't ask me for
money so I didn't give it to her but
like she's never gonna ask for money but
you see someone who you're comfortable
letting you let her into your home she
works for you like come on just give her
the money
I don't know okay
I guess so I guess we're gonna agree to
disagree here I think we're going to
agree to disagree here I think so okay I
just don't have enough information I
don't I'm sorry what information don't
you have I think I need to know how
close they are no I'm saying information
that neither of us will have okay I need
to know how close they are I need to
know what the question was I need to
know how much money Megan Fox has and I
need to understand this whole sort of is
it a triangle what do you call it yeah
situation Megan Fox's finances are
definitely of interest to me as well and
feel kind of vague vague we were on
Tuesday or whenever we talked about this
we went to her IMDb and she hadn't been
in a movie that we'd heard of since
2016. that's a long time but she was in
Transformers do you for sure she makes
like money now all I know is what I've
learned from Josh and by the way Listen
to Good Guys it's fantastic
is it Josh didn't get royalties for any
of Drake and Josh yeah there's like they
were weird like you think that somebody
is killing it and it's all up to did
their lawyer and contract make it so
that they are killing it yeah there's a
very solid chance that maybe as a woman
in Hollywood she went into Transformers
and is making no money maybe she got I'm
sure she got a huge check then maybe she
blew it on a car and a house and all
this stuff and the economy and everybody
no and she also um or maybe she went
through a divorce where she was the
earner great so he took half her money
and maybe she had 15 prior nail techs
between 2016 and 2022 saying that their
dad also had cancer and asked for 100
grand from each of them and now she's
broke maybe is that fair it's by the way
so fair there's many things we don't
know but based on all the information
I've received so far I don't think Fox
is that coming off amazing
okay you made good points I made good
points right you did crushed it I'm just
saying like as a fellow celebrity right
oh how would you handle a situation like
this celebrity
um if they were my friend truly and I
had the means of course
if they weren't my friend
and I had the means I think that I would
try to co-raise it I think I'd give a
chunk and then I said yeah I'd like to
give all 60 but like 15. yeah exactly
that's that's what I would do yeah
that's what I would do all right next up
we have another update in this Francia
Rhys Selena Gomez insane drama what's
the name Francia Raisa by the way she
stars in How I Met Your Father with Josh
Peck
amazing yes so we're Team Francia
because we're Team Josh okay but you
have to hear that but what's her name
Francia it's not that crazy about her
last name Raisa Raisa it's really not
like a crazy Francia reyesa it's just
the way you said it you're having
trouble saying it admit it um literally
not for instance Francia Risa francaisa
Francia Risa Francia Risa Francia Risa
so say you were wrong and you're done
and I'm done
um okay so I gave you I gave Ben the
backstory in the shower this morning
yesterday Selena together no I'm doing
my makeup every morning
yesterday Selena Gomez wished a happy
birthday for Celine uh Francia Risa her
organ donor who you know a lot of people
have speculated that the two have beef
oh wait you said Ariana Grande
when before
you said Ariana Grande and Francia Risa
Oh I thought then I misspoke okay good
this is Selena Gomez's organ donor great
okay oh she is co-stars with Josh yes
wow we gotta get Josh get the tea no by
the way I gotta get Francie a reason
Good Guys yes
okay so here's the backstory for those
who do not know including Ben Selena got
an organ from this girly the two appear
to stop being friends which is
incredibly bizarre
um they've left like kind of weird
comments on social media kind of fueling
the rumors that they have a beef then
out of nowhere yesterday Selena wishes
her happy birthday Francia doesn't even
follow Selena on Instagram a few hours
later Francis on Instagram wow so that
was the update from yesterday then today
TMZ caught up with her of course TMZ is
asking the questions like what the hell
is going on between you two like it's
good it's not good it's good it's not
good we want to know
so there's a video I highly recommend
you go watch it on TMZ it's very telling
in my opinion so she was in West
Hollywood on Thursday a photographer
asked her about Selena wishing her a
happy birthday which seems to be an
olive branch during their falling out so
Francia says I got a lot of birthday
messages and I appreciate everyone who
sent me but she didn't even address
Selena she was just saying thanks it's
all good
so Vince then she gets in the car and
the photographer is like you know what's
going on with you and Selena like is
there beef
and she's like no beef
and then the guy was like was there ever
beef
have a good day guys that's what she
says so I think this video was meant to
clear it up I'm even more suspicious I
need a body language expert watching
this video it's so not settling anything
for me if anything I'm even more
incensed I'm such a conspiracy theorist
when it comes to the Saga and this video
is making me feel like it's not even a
conspiracy like these two are not
friends
what do you think
I think the whole story is very
troubling
well you took like a five second silent
pause just to say that vote of nothing
to give
in Oregon an organ to a friend
you have to be besties yeah well
actually you know what I asked um The
Toasters yesterday if anybody has given
or received an organ to let me know
um what that experience was like and
maybe provide some color and we actually
got a lot of comments from people whose
family members had given a receiver they
themselves had given or received and
they say you go through an extensive
process with a social worker before
agreeing to donate because they want to
make sure nobody's being coerced into
giving a donation they also say you go
through
um like a lot of almost like a lecture
from the social worker making it seem
like you know you're giving someone a
an organ transplant not a personality
transplant so you can't give this to
this person expecting you know for the
rest of their life they're going to be
indebted to you you know you have to
give it because you love them and you
want this person around and that's it
and you have to be comfortable knowing
you know people come and go out of your
life you could maybe not talk to this
person in 10 years
so it was actually very helpful so like
I don't think it's unheard of for you to
not talk to
the person who gave you an organ but
this definitely seems like were they for
sure best friends like the thing is the
first time I ever heard of Francia race
his name was when she was like the girl
who gave Selena a kidney like I don't
know the extent of their friendship so
perhaps they were just you see we never
have all the information and we never
will but perhaps see the whole time out
here thinking they're besties having a
great time Celine is sick friend offers
a kidney boom and then all of a sudden
they're not friends then you think
there's beef perhaps maybe just perhaps
they were never friends she gave her the
kidney they were acquaintances and then
they remained not friends the way that
it seems and there was like a
documentary or something like a video
made Francis I forget what it was but
Francia was talking about it and she
like feel she sounded very uncomfortable
and she also said that like Selena found
out that Francia was a match before
Francia found out
and legally usually the person who's a
match finds out
and they can like say no and the person
will never know that they were even a
match you know because you don't have to
give it but clearly
I don't have to give it
um it's like an awkward based on like
the information we've seen it's a very
weird situation
it's almost like would you give me your
kidney of course but it's almost like
somebody is Rich and somebody is
broke who's broke no I'm just I'm saying
like hypothetically you have a rich
person and a broke person and
the broke person finds out like gets
like the rich person's bank statement
and finds out exactly how much money
they have and goes to them and says hey
you could spare 50 Grand give it to me
that's weird you don't like my analogy I
have no idea how the analogy of Pies the
analogy applies because Selena found out
that she was a match before the person
found out that they were a match so I'm
saying Selena maybe went to this person
and was like I need your kidney we're a
match but the friend maybe just didn't
want to give up their kidney no I know
it's a very but maybe she wasn't a
friend at all the more you look into
this whole situation it is very weird
and it's yeah it's very strange does
anybody know what I'm talking about that
video where Francie is talking about it
and she literally says that Selena knew
she was a match before Francia did I
can't remember what it is it's not in
Selena's documentary but I've seen it
please if you know what I'm talking
about drop a comment very interesting
this episode of the toast is brought to
you by Poise Ultra thins new mamas
listen up because Poise Ultra thins are
that bad now becoming a mom has come
with a lot of big changes and with baby
number two on the way I'm getting ready
to experience some of that all over
again you know the joys of postpartum
life are boundless and every time you
think you've gotten a grasp on something
you discover something really new and
beautiful and wonderful
um
and it's just such a gift so something
super common that we don't always talk
about when it comes to postpartum life
is bladder leaks one in two women over
20 experience bladder leaks and most
young moms try to use period pads to
solve the problem you know make sense or
so you think but actually period pads
aren't designed for pee thankfully Poise
Ultra thins are specifically designed
for bladder leaks and keep you 10 times
drier than the leading period pad this
was not something that I knew at first
and now I'm so glad to know that there
are specific pads designed for bladder
leaks and Poise Ultra thins are the best
ones the Clean dry and fresh protection
these pads provide is a lifesaver and
they're shaped to fit and flex with your
body so you can stay comfortable and
live without compromise Poise Ultra
thins offer with and without wings so
you can live worry-free personally I
have enough on my plate as a mom so I
love the idea of taking one worry off
the list and having the exact tools that
I need when I need them it takes Poise
learn more
poise.com so let's talk about you
potentially giving me a kidney or an
organ one day I would 100 give you one
me too like no questions asked of course
you would yeah interesting but um I'm
kind of surprised why I don't know I
just like
like there's of course of course you
love me but I don't know if you love me
enough to go under the knife I don't
know if you'd want one of my organs I I
can't imagine they're in like the best
condition ever but like if it was a good
one then I wouldn't even without
question without hesitation I'll give it
to you why would you even say that
actually you just don't like surgery I'm
just thinking like don't like surgery
okay so you should die no I oh with life
or death duh no but like I'd give it to
you even if it was like better life not
death oh my God that's so sweet I
wouldn't give it to you for a better
life that's dumb see there you go that's
literally dumb you'd leave me having a
worse life no but like what if things
don't work out between us would you want
it back no that's sick I remember there
was a story about a guy who like gave a
kidney to his wife and they got divorced
years later and he wanted it back really
yeah that is psychotic and it reminds me
of the oscar-snubbed film Rat Race that
I just rewatched on the plane when
Newman is transporting a heart across
state lines have you seen the movie
unbelievable and they lose the heart
it's an organ he's selling the organ oh
we could get into organ farming you want
to do that no why not also very
lucrative George Lopez's wife I believe
gave him a kidney and they ended up
getting divorced too it's bitter
divorced yeah oh
um
did you love that show love but like
thinking back on it like why were they
screaming you're screaming I'm literally
not screaming no sorry it's like a small
room and you were like echoing in my ear
I was by the way it's because the room
has an echo it's not me okay blame the
Rim Yeah I want to go get construction
get the demo
um
bad boy okay good back to George Lopez
yeah they sing that song and it's three
o'clock in the morning and they are
literally just like throwing kids in the
air yeah no nobody actually watched The
George Lopez Show they fell asleep
watching like Nick at night whether it
was the nanny or friends or whatever and
then at two in the morning you hear
scared the [__] out of you and then you
wake up turn the TV off and go back to
sleep I watched it yeah loved George I
was always watching The Nanny before bed
11 o'clock they played two episodes I
was like devastated when the two
episodes were over the nanny was
unbelievable friends rusher fantastic
Queen
um okay ready for our next story
ready Freddy why don't you answer me
when I ask because obviously I'm ready
I'm here like you keep asking such dumb
questions like hey are you here hey are
you conscious hey no hey you you like
yeah I'm here it's an amazing point and
every single time you ask me a question
I answer it so am I ready yeah I'm ready
I'm like I'm here I'm here no it's an
amazing Point okay ready yes
Kim Kardashian brings the world's most
expensive handbag to a soccer game so
Kim is one stylish soccer mom she
casually brought what's widely
considered to be the world's most
expensive handbag to a soccer game on
Tuesday so Kim brought her Hermes
Himalaya bag crocodile Diamond Birkin
bag it costs more than a hundred
thousand dollars but it's estimated to
be worth about three hundred and eighty
thousand dollars to the soccer game
between Al Nasser and Paris
Saint-Germain in Osaka Japan she kept
the rest of her look casual you know who
cares she wore Balenciaga vomit
um but the bag which is like you know
classic it's a Birkin but it's a special
Birkin it's made of Himalayan crocodile
it has diamond encrusted Hardware a
bunch of Real Housewives have it all the
Kardashian girlies have it it is the
world's most expensive handbag how much
is it I just I literally just told you
sorry so you say I'm here I'm listening
and no I didn't say I was listening I
said I'm here because you purchase it if
you by the way the whole point is that
like what I can't get it I get you can't
get it but if Kim obviously you can
purchase it from Hermes if you want to
purchase it it's a hundred thousand
dollars but they go oh you know people
sell them second hand they're on the uh
you know real real well actually they're
not really on the real rail but if you
were to purchase it secondhand from like
a vintage shop you're probably gonna pay
closer to 400 Grand but that's what it's
worth not what it cost yeah wow that
that's crazy
um Kim Kardashian is an unbelievable mom
oh why do you say that because the way
that she has taken her son's interest in
soccer and spent all of her money I get
that she has so much money I get it
she's literally spending all of her
money making his dreams come true taking
him all around the world yeah to soccer
games at literally six years old no he's
six right same yeah whatever it's like
it's unbelievable yeah no it's really
sweet right yeah like I don't think
anybody talks about that what are your
thoughts on like the big new soccer team
is it in Miami messy inter it's not a
new soccer team but Messi joined enter
Miami so you're saying messy Lionel
Messi like the player who I've heard
Lionel Lionel Richie wait is that Lionel
Messi no wait I'm in shock you know no
it's Lionel like I'm sorry okay it's not
he plays in America that said he'd be
lucky to be hello
isn't me you're looking for I'm sure
some of you like Millennial gen Z
hippies were like hello it's me no Adele
ripped that off from Sir Lionel hello do
you think your Lionel Richie's number
one fan I love him okay sing me another
song besides hello
why did you have to do that no I know
others okay fine can you go on Spotify I
just need the names I'm just blanking
for a second okay so you're obviously
not like a huge fan but I'll give you
I'll give you a life raft no no I I'm
literally I'm obsessed with him okay
here we'll play my favorite game okay
when you know the words to the song
sing along
sing along okay ready this is a Lionel
song
my
you're kidding me
I need another word my
I need another word my n
my end
I don't know My Endless Love
well you're really not a Lionel Richie I
am
let me think I'm actually more look let
me explain
let me explain let me know when you're
ready for me okay I got another one
you'll know this one okay fine when you
know though let's do that song
sing along
sing along okay
oh
that long all night
oh night long all night that was good
all night long okay now let me explain
where my fandom for Lionel Richie came
from that cartoon it's important
my fandom for Lionel Richie came when I
looked up the music video for my
favorite song hello is it me you're
looking for
and for anybody have you seen the music
video no the music video is about yeah
it's about a man wait I just want to say
I want to hear what you'd say but you
told this story on the toast I have yeah
but go again the music video is about a
man singing to a blonde girl and there's
something just so touching yet so
bizarre bizarre and humorous about the
song hello is it me you're looking for
and when the woman on the receiving end
can't see wait no they took a very
literal approach they did hello this is
me you're looking for yes I can't see
anybody here no if they had made that
music video today I think Lionel would
be called ableist yes unbelievable and
now here's the kicker or here's the
question the girl who played the blind
girl in the music video do you think she
was blind amazing question
amazing question
or was she pretending to be blind and
then all of a sudden putting all the
blind actresses out of business when you
say pretending to be mine you mean
acting oh true right oh you're so right
I know wow
wow tough um how do we get here how did
we get here how'd we get out
oh [__] oh soccer oh Lionel oh
[Laughter]
but yes Miami enter okay so hottest
ticket in town so you're telling me like
Lionel Messi whose name I have heard I
don't follow soccer but I know he's a
Cristiano Ronaldo like yeah such a big
he plays in America now he now plays in
America is it like the off season for
him he's gonna go back to Barcelona or
whatever he's on 150 million dollar
contract which by the way for soccer
these days even though that sounds like
an ungodly amount of money is actually
pennies oh wow because of not Penny
because of the Saudis the Saudis just
offered 771 million for one year Ronaldo
I think just took 300 300 million for
one year and Messi is taking 150 for one
year I think it's for one year I mean he
loves America no he has so much baked
into this deal like stake in the team
streaming a stake in streams like
there's something with Apple so when
Miami inter plays teams they play other
American states yes and American soccer
is slowly becoming a thing it's becoming
a thing because they're getting like
MetLife
they would play at MetLife yes does New
York have a team we have the uh it's
nycfc oh yeah I've heard of it um
remember I went to a game they actually
gave me a jersey lovely I think it was
at Yankee Stadium they put you on the
Jumbotron because you're a celebrity
they did exactly yeah yeah that's cool
yeah it was cool so that's New York City
Football Club I believe so yes and then
there's the New York Red Bulls I've
heard of them too yeah which is a
different different team but like those
it's like ushered in from like an age
where like American soccer kind of stunk
yeah like now American soccer is here
what in Turkey let me ask you another
question so we all grew up at least for
girls like what a hero I feel of many
girls was MIA ham what did she play in
America you were asking the wrong guy
yeah like why did we all love or was she
an Olympian she was probably an Olympian
oh yeah because then it's like World Cup
it's typical and it's like all the
girlies I follow on Instagram like from
that
uswnt yeah typically when there's a a
beloved women's athlete she was an
Olympian right right because because
that's when you get the most air time
yeah yeah that's true that's true but
what Miami inter has done yeah with
these gorgeous pink jerseys have you
seen them and how was David Beckham
involved is he like I think he's an
owner yeah sick jerseys very like live
in La Vida Loca in Miami yeah Messi
three goals I think he had in his first
two games guy is killing it yeah Kim
went to the the first game that's who I
that's what I thought you were saying
and I was thinking to myself they're
calling this thing whoever wrote that
article a soccer game it's not a soccer
game it was a big deal this is a who's
who yeah
Serena Williams LeBron James where did
they play in Miami no idea okay like at
the football stadium no I'm saying just
does soccer games because it's so
Un-American do soccer games get played
in football stadiums I think that soccer
games typically would get played in
soccer stadiums but because they don't
have soccer stadiums well we could I
don't know maybe they built one for
inter they probably play like hard rock
yeah I guess where the Dolphins play
yeah again another thing that we could
easily look up but I know you're against
looking things up so we're just gonna
speculate because this is the podcast of
people who know nothing but have a good
time exploring options understood
understood you can look it up on your
own where they play
um but Messi is great should we get into
soccer yeah and it's funny I actually
owe him a text back I texted my friend
who's at nycfc who's now no longer at
nycfc he's at MetLife but uh inter is
playing nycfc in September and we're
gonna get tickets and we're gonna go
watch Messi oh that's cool in New York
Lionel yeah Lionel hello I'm in shock
his name isn't Lionel yeah it's not
because I've never like been with people
who talk about him they just write about
him so I'm like Lionel and then if I was
ever like with someone who has you know
been talking about soccer they would
call him Messi Messi so this was just a
huge YouTube you taught me so much today
Ben okay good thank you so much I'm
happy now I do have a Fizz story but
like it honestly sucks and I don't want
to waste everyone's time so I could
rather just like talk to you about
literally anything else okay cool so
what's new with you oh good I'm starving
what should we have for lunch today
that's a great question are we going
chain or no chain
I wouldn't because I know what I want
you want the deli yeah the kosher deli I
want Cheesecake Factory
I don't like it
I'm sorry I think Cheesecake Factory is
wholly overrated wow that's like
literally me coming over here and being
like Spritz taste bad like you're just
trying to hurt me that is like so like a
dumb comparison no it's not like really
really
it doesn't make any sense that would be
like me saying that you own Cheesecake
Factory
yeah in my heart that should be our next
let's buy a Cheesecake Factory oh cool
we could service prep so that nobody can
be in it again literally every
Cheesecake Factory I go to is empty I
know we'd have to put it why are they
sell so much real estate so empty we'd
have to open like a small one that's
kind of like Bistro like we'd have a
waiting list we'd be lit we do happy
hours we'd serve Spritz we do meet and
greets I love it let's buy a Cheesecake
Factory yeah but like here's my boot to
pick with cheesecake factors even though
that's a beautiful dream my bone to pick
with them now I'm realizing it such
unbelievable real estate like the Taj
Mahal yeah you walk into a mall it's
gorgeous huge you walk in the foods I
wish it was a PF Chang's yeah imagine if
every cheese for lunch yeah that's
probably good but like then I'm gonna
have diarrhea I know it's too heavy I
know I want to go to like there's like a
place that's like salad bars and like
that kind of stuff yeah like a big
beautiful salad you know but start to
push things down the grief
leafy green leafy greens no I know but
like I love a chain restaurant they're
so comfortable I love to sit and at a
chain like we always eat like animals so
yeah those like salad places are nice
but they're always grab and go like I
want an experience most underrated chain
on three one but let me think
was underrated chain on three
I don't know one two three Denny's oh
great sick let's go find a Denny's
[__] Denny's is so good [__]
Denny's bro so good another under Eddie
underrated chain I actually think they
could be out of business one two three
friendlies
I didn't know we were still playing so
good I've actually never been to a
Friendly's what came first I'm assuming
that the the friendlies uh chain came
before The Friendly Ice Cream yeah sits
in like the Walmarts yeah targets and
stuff right
um but like really delicious that's our
show no but like we'll do it again most
underrated chain okay wait let me find
three you give me a second
by the way do you know any chains oh I
got it three two one Sonic
I've never been I just went for the
first time for our mukbang then it was
the best place I've ever been in my life
really you have to go they say that they
have 99 cent smoothies is that true they
have there are no are they smoothies or
slushies they have everything smoothies
slushies milkshakes they're known for
like their drinks they make these like
really creative they have drinks collab
with Red Bull like Dr Pepper like they
have all these cool collabs and does it
have anything to do with the Hedgehog
it's an amazing question I don't think
so it's just separate Sonic yeah
interesting
all right that was Friday's episode I
hope you guys have an amazing weekend uh
Monday Jackie's not back because she's a
doctor's appointment so Monday I have
someone joining us
honestly I'm not sure if I'm going to be
in New York or Florida but I have plans
for both so we'll see what happens
Monday it'll be a surprise hope you guys
have an amazing weekend I love you so
much thank you so much for listening to
the toast the Millennium Morning Show
where we deliver the fast five stories
you need to know every Monday through
Friday on YouTube so if you're watching
this on YouTube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as podcasting
where podcasts can be found so it's
Spotify
listen podcast review about a beautiful
setting and wickedly talented we are
hope you guys have an amazing weekend we
love you dearly and we'll see you on
Monday bye